[Music]
[Music]
the carrot iana are an indigenous group
here in Brazil they live on protected
land deep in the Amazon rainforest when
it was established in 1986 it was
surrounded by rainforests but today it's
almost completely surrounded by farms
this kind of encroachment is happening
across the Amazon Brazil has over 400
protected indigenous lands but it's
booming agricultural industry has spent
the past few decades clearing the
rainforest around them
now they want in and they have the
perfect Ally to help them no this is
only regard don't take my video Brazil
Brazilian President jarba Sandero wants
the expansion of farms to continue even
at the expense of protected lands and
that's put 900,000 indigenous people at
the risk of losing their homes and their
way of life using to prepare for this
[Music]
cheering - am i - aah - man thank our
standard garden is not an engine but
they give you some very unexpected
perfectly
rejection efika tirado whom des métiers
metate shagging movie Mitch
I got a mustiness keyframe pack
pinkie print an E
Roma will kick you back on this thing
[Music]
at the start of the 20th century Brazil
was intent on becoming a modern country
cities along the coast were already
being developed but the Amazon which
covers almost half the country was
remote inaccessible and home to tens of
thousands of indigenous people who had
lived there for centuries around the
1920s brazil's government pushed an
aggressive plan to change the shape of
the amazon
it brought telegraph lines roads schools
and people into the amazon while
forcibly pushing these indigenous groups
out of the way then in the 1960s a
brutal military dictatorship took over
brazil and carried out genocide against
indigenous people they took away their
lands to build highways mines and dams
across the Amazon during this time more
than eighty three hundred and isness
people were killed and tens of thousands
had lost their homes
in 1985 the military regime collapsed
and Brazil became a democracy the new
constitution included historic
reparations for the country's indigenous
people it recognises their culture and
traditions and even gave them a way to
get their lands back indigenous groups
could claim their traditional territory
with a government agency called Funai
that would demarcate the borders of a
new protected land after final approval
from Brazil's president who now would
then monitor and protect it may guess my
size paranoid mi casa le multi-button
proposed me Perico minivan Janine who
came up my professor must say good
answer give us a thing
soon protected indigenous lands are
being set up all over the Amazon and
today they make up around 13% of the
country which includes the care chiana's
land but it wasn't long before these
lands would be threatened again from the
90s to 2000 Brazil's economy was one of
the fastest growing in the world
fuelled primarily by agriculture the
country became one of the top producers
of beef and soybeans while logging and
mining were also significant industries
but the economic boom had a downside all
of these industries needed more and more
land a lot of which came from the Amazon
the rainforest was rapidly cut down in
Para
Rondonia and Mata Grosso States to make
room for cattle pastures and farms often
leaving the protected indigenous lands
as the only forests left before long
Brazil's agricultural industry wanted to
gain access to these areas too and they
found support within the government they
lobbied to weaken the rules around
protected indigenous lands that they
claimed were barriers to progress and
their pressure started to show results
from 2003 to 2010 President Lula da
Silva approved 87 indigenous reserves
but its successor Dilma Rousseff
approved just 21 followed by Michel
temer who
only one Rousseff antemer also cut
through noise funding which forced the
agency to close dozens of offices in the
Amazon leaving indigenous people
unprotected as Funes Power declined
illegal invasions of protected
indigenous lands increased high quality
nice clothes Tamaki no game cohosh today
my daddy hated me I know you stamina you
got that by 2017 Brazil's indigenous
were under attack
bloggers ranchers and farmers felt
embolden under a government heavily
influenced by the agricultural industry
and soon the man leading Brazil's
presidential race would further tip the
scales in their favor as a former member
of the army during the military regime
he shared many of their oppressive
political views especially those towards
indigenous groups
[Music]
de vacas competi mich disco lights he's
sick okay whoever did that these words
earned him the endorsement of the
agricultural industry but deeply word
indigenous groups today makisu Kanta
Flores for you practicing additional
capital key food area me please follow
the support money noises see choose a
massage
as soon as Boston era took office he
turned his attention to the indigenous
he /foo knives budget and hasn't
approved any new lands in fact he's
proposed taking away foon eyes power to
demarcate new lands entirely and he's
appointed a former police officer with
strong ties to the agricultural industry
to lead Funai under balsa narrow
invasions of indigenous lands have
skyrocketed in just the first nine
months of 2019 just 10 days after Boston
era took office in January 20 1940 armed
men invaded this land by May 20 thousand
illegal miners had invaded the Yanomami
reserve and in July invaders cleared a
huge section of forest in the citrine
land the carrot iana are worried that
they could be next
illegal agricultural activities have
been happening here right next to the
care T on the land and they brought
actual threats of violence to the people
living there if we Macedonia watch me
FAK says mez st. proud day
industrialists are burdened all day you
know puja visit an Akuma deunan
es la luz que tu fais pas de los
territory so masado in the past the
indigenous groups had Funai a protective
agency they could turn to for help but
now they're left to rely on themselves
[Music]
okay acaba for the day I posted a
DeMarcus and a preserver New Jersey she
for them a preserve our quiche attained
Canada's energy policy she'd be
poisoning
[Music]
hi thanks for watching the third and
final episode of vox atlas the amazon
mini series my name is ana tejada EG and
i'm a video journalist based in brazil i
went to the Amazon to report on the
ground and to meet with the people who
provided us with invaluable information
I want to thank them all for their time
and for sharing their concerns with us
make sure to watch the serious previous
videos the first one explains what
drives the first station in the rain
forest and in the second video we take a
look at the rubber industry in the
Amazon and the work and legacy of chico
mendes thanks again for watching